♪♪♪
>> EIGHT SECONDS FLAT.
EVEN BETTER THAN LAST WEEK.
>>
>> WOW, I DIDN'T THINK I CAN GET
ANY FASTER.
>> OH, I SEE YOU FINALLY MADE TO
WORK, EVANS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
DID YOU WALK HERE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> REAL FUNNY, IAN.
>> HEY, ARE YOU OKAY?
>> YEAH, I'M FINE.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> AS YOU ALL KNOW IT IS A BIG
WEEK FOR US SO I PRINTED OUT
SOME COPIES OF -- OH, NO, I LEFT
THEM DOWN THE HALL.
♪♪♪
WOW.
OKAY.
WELL, EVERYONE TAKE A GOOD LOOK
AT THESE AND -- KEEP IT UP IAN.
THAT WAS FAST.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I HATE HIM.
>> SO HE'S FAST.
BIG DEAL.
>> YOU DON'T GET IT.
WHEN YOU CAN RUN LIKE THAT YOU
HAVE GOT IT ALL, MONEY, ALL OF
THOSE.
>> WHY DON'T YOU RACE HIM.
>> I HAVEN'T RUN FOR YEARS.
>> YOU USED TO RUN AROUND THE
OFFICE ALL THE TIME.
♪♪♪
>> YEAH, BUT THEN THIS HAPPENED.
>> YOU MADE A COMPLETE FOOL OUT
OF YOURSELF ONCE.
WHO IS TO SAY YOU CAN'T RUN FAST
AGAIN.
>> AND RISK GETTING ANOTHER HOLE
IN MY PANTS?
I'D RATHER [ BLEEP ] KILL
MYSELF.
>> I AM GOING TO NEED SOMEONE TO
RUN DOWN THE HALL AND PICK UP
THE SIGNED DOCUMENTS TOMORROW.
>> EVAN WILL DO IT.
>> WHAT?
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU DOING?
>> EVANS?
HUH.
WELL, I'LL LET YOU GUYS DECIDE.
>> WELL, WELL, WELL, WHAT HAVE
YOU GOTTEN YOURSELF INTO, EVAN?
>> WHY DON'T YOU LEAVE IT TO
SOMEBODY WHO ISN'T SLOW.
>> OKAY, DO YOU WANT TO GET THE
SIGNED DOCUMENTS?
WHY DON'T WE RACE FOR IT?
WINNER GETS -- THE SIGNED
DOCUMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT EVANS.
AFTER HOURS, RECEPTION.
BE THERE.
THAT IS IF YOU ARE NOT TOO BUSY
BEING SLOW.
♪♪♪
>> WHAT HAVE I GOTTEN MYSELF
INTO?
>> LISTEN.
I'LL TRAIN YOU.
>> WHAT?
>> I USED TO RUN FAST, TOO.
WELL, BEFORE THIS HAPPENED.
>> OH.
>> I UNDERSTAND IF YOU DON'T
WANT MY HELP.
>> WAIT, LINDSEY.
OR SHOULD I SAY COACH?
>> FASTER.
I THINK MY WORK HERE IS DONE.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> READY?
♪♪♪
>> SHE WAS A GHOST.
>> ALL RIGHT EVERYBODY, LET'S
JUMP RIGHT IN.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, LINDSEY TURNED
OUT TO BE A GHOST.
THAT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING I NEED TO
TELL YOU.
EVANS IS GOING TO PICK UP THE
SIGNED DOCUMENTS FROM DOWN THE
HALL.
HE'S THE FASTEST MAN FOR THE
JOB.
>> OH, NO NEED.
I CAME IN A LITTLE EARLY AND I
GOT THEM MYSELF.
>> OKAY.
NO PROBLEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE
DO HERE BUT LET'S GET TO WORK.